[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
benji miller will be on the call game
one western conference semis between the
nuggets and the suns tonight
that's 10 eastern on tnt the hall of
famer
reggie joins us on the program could we
ever get you into the boxing ring and
fight uh
floyd mayweather i mean everybody else
is getting in the ring reg
well i'm sure there's some some fellows
i would love to get into the ring with
uh no um i give a lot of credit
to uh ocho cinco for doing that
there is absolutely zero percent
you would get those gloves on me and i
am a
i consider myself a boxing aficionado i
love the sport
i love going to the big prize fights
but it takes a different switch
to be a boxer mma fighter it
it's it's a little different what if i
put you in there against uh
taishan prince
like see he's a nice guy okay but height
and weight
you know i'm trying to get or do i want
to say how would you do against muggsy
bogues
mugsy might get me you know i know you
might get me
but it's but you didn't you're not a
fighter
right you're an agitator
but i did have my share of scraps while
i played
um just trying to create space for
myself but i am not a fighter
i'm a lover as mj said in that video
with paul mccartney
i'm not a fighter i'm a lover oh i
thought you were talking about michael
jordan
i was thinking michael jordan was in a
video with no mccartney
no michael jackson paul mccartney say
how would it go if you and michael
jordan got in the ring
it wouldn't go well for me
[Laughter]
it wouldn't go well for me
yeah i would always tell these guys like
chad ocho cinco
actually did pretty well the first three
rounds
keep your gloves up yeah just that
because you get tired and these guys
drop their gloves or they want to act
like they're ali and you know they're
gonna dance or sugar ray leonard i'm
like keep
keep your glove boom gets tagged right
on the jaw
what was great about that is after his
knockdown when he got out i don't know
if he was a little delirious when he was
trying to give him a high five
you we laugh at that but we don't know
the level of pain
that chad was going through right he
just wanted to give him a high five
what's the best title fight that you've
ever witnessed
in person
i would probably have to say
because it was a spectacle i'm gonna go
with with
floyd and manny just for the simple fact
there was so much hype that was leading
up to it
and it merged pop culture
the sport of boxing together
because it was an event it just wasn't a
boxing match it was an event
and to have ringside seats to
be a part of that and feel the
atmosphere
because there is it's something
different from a prize fight
than running out of a tunnel for an nba
game
the atmosphere because you have betting
sides you you have guys that are
solely on floyd and that were solely on
manny
and it was hype so to be a part of that
was kind of cool
uh we're talking to reggie miller reg
will be on the call it's nuggets sons
game one western conference finals that
will be
semi-finals that'll be at 10 eastern on
tnt
let me start with the james harden
interview or
at least that conversation of he goes
off the floor
and it didn't look terrible but
steve nash said he he felt horrible like
that like this was
big news bad news but james didn't give
us the impression that
this might be something where he's not
even playing in this series
what did you take away from that moment
well again
only an athlete will know his body his
or her body
the best um to me what it sounded like
is
this is something that's kind of been an
ongoing
obviously he's had issues with his
hamstrings this season
where he's re-aggravated them but it
looks like leading
up to this that it was still on the
fringe of something being wrong
and for it to happen that quickly in the
beginning of game
one um hamstrings groins
what anthony davis had those are things
that are
that take time to recover from um i
would not be surprised
if he probably misses this series and if
they're fortunate to get to the
conference finals he comes back for that
but on the flip side because of physical
therapy and treatment
um if he can come back by gains 405
that wouldn't surprise me as well um but
you know it's going to linger reg
that that is that it's going to stay
with him the rest of this postseason
and his type of game which is short
explosive moves that's all hamstrings
that's all growing so it's all connected
i i feel for them because you know
to me they are it's theirs to lose down
even with him going down
they still have kyrie they still have kd
it to me it's still theirs to lose
but you want to be a part of that you
know and he is a big
huge part of the success of the nets and
you would like to see him out there
everything okay with the clippers now
that they've moved on
no it's not it's great that they
advanced
but there's a lot of questions and just
because they got by the dallas mavericks
and luca
in the first round what's waiting for
them is the best
passing and shooting team in the nba in
the utah gems
so they kind of wanted this because they
thought they were they were going to
avoid the lakers now the lakers are out
but you're going against a very
dangerous offensive weapon
in the utah jazz no one has given them
credit
their only loss was when donovan
mitchell did not play in game one versus
memphis
they go off and run four straight
against memphis if they shoot the ball
the problem with dallas was luca and at
times
uh hardaway was really their only
offensive weapons for the mavericks
the jazz have four or five guys that can
flat
out shoot the basketball they spread you
out
this could be a very tough and long
series for the clippers
how do you build around luca
it's very difficult because he's ball
dominant and that's not a bad thing
you know you look at the 14 assists last
night i mean he was
he not only was he scoring but he was
setting up his teammates as well
it's difficult because you've got to
find bigs that can stretch the floor
that can play in the high pick and roll
and you that's why you thought porzingis
was a perfect fit for them
that should be your go-to money play
porzingis
luca end of game how are you going to
play it you switch
luca can kill the bigs or you could put
porzingis
someone in the post but porzingis has
been very disappointed
all season to me he was injury plagued
so i don't know how you build around him
because it's not like they need a point
guard because he is the point guard on
that team
you need bigs that can stretch the floor
and shoot
would you keep porzingis
personally no i would see what i can get
for him but it depends on what i'm going
to get in return
um for him to say that he felt that his
role was diminished or they didn't use
him well
he had plenty of opportunities to be
to make an imprint in this in that
series
and he didn't um especially you know
when they went up 3-2 going home
that that to me that was the series
right there they weren't going to close
it out at home being up
3-2 then it was going to be very
difficult to win game seven
in staples who's the best player in the
nba
i will always go with a healthy lebron
james as the best
player just for the simple fact that he
does everything
even now even now healthy i said
healthy yeah i mean before he went down
with the ankle injury he was
in the discussion for the mvp he was one
of the top three candidates
before the ankle injury i mean he's
going to give you 25
8 and 8. i mean i will take that plus
what he
what he does lifting up his teammates
but i mean there's an off night for luca
though reg
serious contenders for the crown luca
i mean what steph has done at 32 soon to
be 33
kevin durant i mean there's there's a
lot of guys coming for that crown
giannis a two-time mvp but he has
flaws in my opinion i mean it's hard for
me to say he's the best player
when there's serious flaws in his game
uh
the mvp this year i think it's going to
be jokage
you know we're going to see him tonight
um versus deandre hayden which i'm
excited to see
up and coming young center versus the
potential mvp
and then joel and pete has a torn
meniscus and goes out and gets
39 in game one in philadelphia right
so there are serious guys for the crown
of that best player in the league dan
but
a healthy lebron james at 35-36
it's hard to shy away from that who do
you like in your series
no good sons
you would think that denver has the edge
because they have experience they were
in the conference finals last year
versus the lakers uh they understand how
to win tough series being down
3-1 twice last year in the bubble
finding ways to win
but something is growing here in the
desert monty williams just has
these guys clicked in and with the
injury to chris ball
i thought that series was over if he
wasn't going to be able to come back and
be helpful
but cameron payne was fantastic off the
bench
jay crowder has found his shot he was
two of 20
from threes in the first three games in
that series went 12 or 20 the rest of
the way
his toughness
i i think it's going to be a very
difficult series
but i have phoenix winning in seven but
you can make a case for denver as well
in seven but i think this is going the
distance between these two teams
jake crowder is not afraid of lebron
james
no like he's not like he he gets right
in his face it's almost as if he says to
lebron what are you going to do
because i'm not afraid of you i get
that's interesting because you you
normally don't
see somebody step up to somebody like
that i mean think of all the great
players in the game in the history of
the game
like who stood up right in somebody's
face and basically
is trying to emasculate you like jay
crowder wants lebron to know
i don't care who you are i'm gonna be
right here
the whole time and i think that gave
the inexperience other than chris paul
the inexperienced sons
life juice and i think it's going to be
that toughness
that is why they will prevail in seven
games
versus denver people have a pick um
series between these two
but to me the key will be deandre ayton
versus jokage
who can get the other sinner in foul
trouble if if eighteen is in foul
trouble
advantage denver denver wins the series
if ayden can stay out of foul trouble
and stay on the floor and play jokic
one-on-one
and neutralize them which is easier said
than done
and you could stay home with the
shooters advantage sons
sons won the series we were talking
about this earlier mclovin thinks that
trey young you know you can't put your
hands on
you can't rough him up you know in
today's nba that if
you're playing when you played like trae
young will be put on his butt
a couple of times in a series but as
so the nba is basically saying that we
don't want this to ever happen again
we we want to protect our players we
don't want guys getting knocked down
you know there's no jordan rules here
there's no bad boys with the pistons
so you think that that is the nba is
is doing this on purpose not just for
trey young but
we're not going to allow this to happen
in basketball again they want scoring up
they want freedom of movement and what
does that do that puts the casual fans
in the stands because they want to see
spectacular plays
they want to see trey young knock down
30 35 footers
they want to see him shoot floaters from
the free throw line
without being put on his behind that
puts the casual fan not the hardcore fan
the casual fans will come to game they'd
be like hey
that's that tree that's the guy that
took on new york that's the guy who
you know ice tray and was telling the
crap the casual fan
wants to see that and that's no
disrespect to trey
because he is slowly becoming if not
already
a household name for what his his
exploits in new york and what he
potentially could do in philly against
two marquee
franchises so i have no problem
with that but this has been going on for
a while the freedom of movement this is
not new this season freedom movement
really started
the beginning of 2000. commissioner
stern wanted
scoring to be up he didn't want the
bloodbath between
detroit new york indiana holding
clutching hitting
scores 85 to 90. they want that up there
120-125
that's what it is today when did they
start allowing the
players to carry the basketball
that's been on since the beginning of
time
no no it was ivory iverson and stockton
are
those guys right away yeah
but now now it's not even it's never
called
no like it's you can have your hands
wait under the ball
and then like it's i mean come on
there's no traveling myself on
fundamentals coming from ucla that's
all they
do you think though like iverson carried
all the time right
yes all the time and stockton
and and tim hardaway yes yeah
and kobe a little bit and if you
and if you had a handle then you may be
hold on that's right yeah that's all you
did
right there all i need is that elbow
there we go see that elbow
i know you you're one of the great
shooters in history but i wouldn't teach
your form to anybody
no not at all it was very unorthodox
it was invented out of getting my
shot blocked nine out of ten times for
my older sister and older brothers
i couldn't shoot like this right in
front of them because it kept going back
so i would do this and kind of push it
over them
and that's where that was born from do
you have a basketball there with you
i don't i'm in the hotel here in phoenix
and
why would i travel with a basketball
theodore i don't know
i do you travel with a basketball
on the road yes it's my best friend i
get a seat for the basketball when i fly
first class first class for my
basketball see
this is why this is why you and my dance
are winning emmys tomorrow
this is exactly why you guys are winning
kimmies tomorrow because you guys
feel you're getting an emmy if we win an
emmy
you're gonna be a winner reggie you're
finally gonna be a winner
[Laughter]
i'm gonna get up i'm gonna i just wanna
okay we are going to win tomorrow okay
look i'm just telling everyone
after the game tomorrow morning i'm
walking and you've been to the valley
center you've heard of camelback
mountain people hiking right out there
yeah i'm going to the top of camelback
tomorrow
sunrise the sun's coming up i'm going to
say a little prayer
could you remember could you videotape
you at the top of camelback mountain
video and send it to you
of my acceptance speech of us winning an
emmy all right i'm going to play that
tomorrow night on the the viewing party
and we will play that video and then uh
the after party i think lil kim is going
to perform
yeah i think i think it is
booked yeah big entourage yeah yeah
the green room is going to be nice yeah
i think little kim is going to perform
uh who else uh is missy miss elliott's
in
yeah yeah i just found out yeah yeah we
are sparing no no expense here
this is why hey emmy's baby
yes yes
[Laughter]
and we we tried to get hall of oats but
we could only get oats
but uh and then i asked paulie to get
cisco
he said yes immediately said yes
immediately
uh have fun tonight reg and uh we will
we will have you in our hearts tomorrow
night
thank you i am sending my acceptance
speech of
our emmy yes yes thank you buddy
that's uh reggie aloysius miller jr the
third hall of famer he'll be on the call
tonight
at 10 eastern on tnt it's nuggets and
the sun's
rally in the valley